oh no but I don't wanna go in the turn
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to security breach
as in the ruins that we left last time I
didn't think led to anything else
happening in the story but here we are
again oh
look at this place see I've said this
before but I'll say it again I actually
had fond memories of this I liked it
when it helped me blurb time oh God no
so we're gonna play warning we recommend
completing security breach first for the
I know Freddy exploded or something like
that he got ex he got two
Freddy's your son of a and I'll
never forgive him anyway I'm gonna
forgive him if he's available there and
he's he's a cuddly teddy bears he should
be I'm gonna forgive him immediately
unless he's horrible and nightmarish
fine Gregory Gregory is lost he'll find
him
I don't wanna
I don't wanna Gregory is trapped in the
pizza Plex only you can see oh am I
Freddie or am I somebody else I'm
probably not Freddy in this situation
[Music]
yes
who are you
who am I
who are we
Pizza Plex destroyed that's all
Gregory
you there
I got your message
what message I don't remember sending a
message in the last one
Gregory are you there I have are you
there
hey Gregory where are
all right all right Gregory's not here
well this is lovely let's see
um
wow welcome back come back okay pardon
our mess we'll be back soon uh okay
I don't get it why would Gregory tell me
to come to this old place and then not
be here
what is that
maybe if I get up there I can see better
yeah or maybe if we run away immediately
we'll survive
um but also it doesn't seem like Gregory
was here
recently
fine on me
what is this sound because it seems to
be coming from behind me and that means
that it's coming from outside
don't go in alone
well about that
I'm kind of alone hey wait a minute that
looks important
who is you you gonna scare me you gonna
jump scare me I'll take that thank you
very much why is this taking so long
all right
oh that was good I got a flashlight
view info you know I want to know info
for those dark and scary places
I don't know this is gonna actually
permeate into the real life what are you
what are you supposed to be what are you
doing back there
what you doing
all right
get a complimentary entry pass of course
of course I remember
I remember very distinctly okay good
good great even excellent fantastic well
that looks awful
anybody here whoa
I don't know about you I don't remember
that
huh
okey-dokey then
hello
so this is one of the stores that was
near the uh the entrance here
uh-huh
did you guys see something did you guys
hear something
yeah I don't know one
what
that's just destroying the bitrate on my
video
oh you almost did
when I explicitly told you to don't
that literally almost killed me great
good to know anybody else here hi
anybody else here
hi
okay
hello
oh if I didn't get the other flashlight
I already got one I can dual wield them
though that'd be fun
if give
all right fine man not that I really
need it
hey
who's there oh no it's nothing
ah
the doors always do that in the last
thing
all right
that seems good
well
play that back
huh Greg
Gregory
big
Greg
where are you Greg
oh skitters
yeah it's definitely isn't a trap hi
Greg oh no
uh-huh Gregory
uh I got your message where are you
hello
Raceway
[Music]
under Roxy racers
that's all the way on the other side
I'm not even close
wait when does this take place info you
know I want to learn more
of your favorite character okay well
that that tells a lot about you you know
I'm fine nothing to worry about there so
this seems like a bit of a time Jump in
between the game before and the game now
because
yeah
sure wish I could have seen that
now I'm not gonna question the game of
having a little bit of a low frame rate
because remember I
put everything on Ultra so what I'm
gonna do
I'm gonna turn it down just a bit
just a high but uh 2490s clearly isn't
enough
oh boy
well this is new
I don't exactly know where I am
but I have a funny feeling that I need
to go in here and it's going to be
terrible all right
let's see what happens aren't I tiny
aren't I a child I feel like I could
stand up in this
I'm in the game
why is it why is it always sounding like
there's things behind
okay that's not me
I thought that was me moving this on me
the reason it sounds like it's coming
from behind me is because probably just
coming from behind me
this is fine
that is excessively oh
I'm okay
I'm okay who are you telling that to
oh boy
well this is nice that's nice this is
all so nice
oh yeah
okay
yeah that's where you put the trash
because what I don't get about like
destroyed places is trash bags suggest
they tried to clean up at some point why
in the oven
maybe because it's all garbage and it
needs to be thrown away anyway
probably
all right
what is that supposed to be
why is there a bird thing
or is there a dippy drinky bird
unless you're trying to distract me from
something else
no didn't think so
okay hi
chica what happened to you
you look awful yeah
yeah
uh-huh
I don't know oh who put trash in chica
this is exactly what I was talking about
unless chica ate that
which is entirely possible
that is actually 100 possible I
I don't want to think about that
okay
I'm sure that chica is gonna stay behind
there in that room and not come after me
man they really put poop all over the
walls
and the ceiling
and the floor all right
and in my pants
what is this supposed to be
those aren't good sounds I know good
sounds those aren't good sounds
okay at least the heat lamp is still
working that's an efficient way to light
the space not ominous
never I'm no you guys no
there's that
a fast wrench
it's just like my dad what
what do you mean wait uh stop is that
supposed to mean some I need more info
a Fazbear technician's fast wrench is
your dad a Fazbear
technician
and also I went to engineering school
for at least four years so I think I
know what a wrench looks like
that ain't it
oh this is the safe Point what is this
what am I looking at let me wrench this
up
point the fast wrench at the conduit to
charge
ah
it's for babies
it's for babies it's a puzzle for babies
I know what I'm doing
I'm no baby hmm seems like someone was
trying to keep something in or out
okay
what do you do needle
I vaguely remember the places and it's
not just because it's been a while oh
something about that but also it's just
because
everything is smeared with poop I don't
know how long it needs to be for things
to become poop smeared that is a hundred
percent poof and I don't know how it got
there I don't know what that is wait
it's not poop it's Lube it's oil from
the the thing
you know what I'm talking about no
that's not what it is
you know molten Freddy whatever it's
called oh hi I should have been looking
this way is that where the thing
happened
to Hole In The Wall was there something
that happened here
do it again
ah it's not gonna do it again is it do
it again
I swear I'll look I'll look this time
don't do it again
do it don't do it do it
don't you ladies and gentlemen
I thought you're going to a dubstep
remix
nice head
all right
well it looks like you're not gonna do
it so
oh hi what are you doing back here just
holding on to your last positions
all right well that's spooky oh wow
I thought it was gross but it is gross
but also it was a toy chica I thought it
was something
else okay
that's terrible
can I crawl under this
can I get under there
can I go prone
oh no
but I don't wanna go
[Music]
foreign
it does seem like there's a lot more
polish
ow my head
where's that freaking Monty thing go
okay I think I could find a way out
before it comes back yeah maybe screw
Gregory I'm howdy is that flesh wall
okay there we go
all right Monty's golf why does it look
like
I've been swallowed
by an enormous creature hello
how are you
Monty
is that you
oh it's been so long Monty come back
uh
please take a mask take a mask take a
mask
oh I didn't even know that's what that
was ah why what
um
all right
hi
thank you thank you please enjoy I will
it's not a Bonnie mask
how the wires
okay thanks for that the last thing you
did was give me this one yeah give me
info
point but you're not giving me good info
here but I guess this is all a kid would
know I suppose
all right I'll equip it that's not gonna
change my existence
oh Manny virtual augmented neural
network integration unit that seems safe
for a developing mind like mine
new user oh wait a what I just wondering
oh that hurts well
maybe do not be surprised by your
surroundings you're still in the real
world but Fazbear entertainment has made
it better
this is what Apple wants with apple
Vision with this security mask you can
locate and repair all the pesky security
nodes that are locking down the mesh
Network here in the mega Pizza Plex call
me helpy you can always count on me
because it's my job to help you succeed
in your new job
right
oh what
oh
it's uh beautiful
what are you still doing here and what
are you still doing here
lucky for you the transpondering plan
allows me to communicate wirelessly even
when your mask is removed wirelessly how
just another fast amazing benefit of
being a class 5 technician of course you
will have to put your mask back on to
get any real work done okay
way better than a fast watch that was
dumb as hell nobody like that
anyway
I'm gonna try to forget about this
uh
uh something wrong with this box
ain't real
is it a normal side effect of the Mask
oh hello
okay it's hard to look at why is hard to
look at what do you mean
that's what it meant by AR versus real
um but also why why why would it be hard
to look at I find it perfectly easy to
look at
[Music]
oh
now see I don't know about that I feel
like the Matrix is well I mean where's
the FNAF going to go at this point
besides the Matrix so you know what I'm
I'm all for it
I just don't know about the reality of
it let's see which one is faster you
know about the same
I'm so smart
oh hello
friend
how are you doing
oh
fascinating
you're just as I remember
what are you guarding in here also what
do you look like in VR
all right that's fine that's fine
that's not horrible
hey wait a minute
I know a glitch in The Matrix when I see
it
I swear that Dory was blocked uh-huh
didn't you already learn this
hello
[Music]
wait what
stop doing cool things behind me
what did you do
well so why is there a trail of what
looks like digital blood flowing that
away oh no that's your flashlight no
that's digital blood me hops
I guess sinner
in a reality where
the digital and the physical as in The
Souls of
children can be stuffed into
animatronics this isn't that crazy and
probably this is how it happened
so I guess I
foreign
so what's going on with blockade here
well this is going to take some getting
used to but I'm very smart and extremely
handsome so I think I can do it
okay what is this ah it's just like my
dad
thankfully we're on the same page
Fazbear technician remote camera station
locally for you it's already exploited
as an active wow that's great these
little box uh oh
oh
okay select the camera to see what it
sees okay
please flashing intercom button
are you there
my boy voice
fun trick huh I created it using samples
of your voice what's with the
hey helpy I just noticed your purple
hey you got weird veins
all right oh there oh it's all good
experienced employees use intercom
recordings like this to direct
animatronic performance at specific
locations you know for autographs and
photo ops
look I'm sure they do
um but also
kind of weird why I press numbers and it
won't go to the oh I see
shouldn't I be here
are you there oh wait I don't want to
lead you oh wait hold on a second
hold on just a second if I look in
reality here
that doesn't make any sense
oh no this is where I am
I thought I was somewhere else ah
okay it's looking up opposite side all
right so that's good
so what I need to do I think is lure it
in a place where I could probably get
away from it but I don't even know how
I'm gonna do that
whatever let's just go forth let's see
what happens I'll let my instincts guide
me
I don't need to actually know what I'm
doing
because I have
done it before
could I play this
is this still yeah
hi it's me
um you would have thought that I would
have gotten smarter in the interim but I
didn't and I didn't learn my lesson so I
played this game for no reason for a
very long time you don't want to see it
because nothing happens
okay are you pointing where I'm supposed
to go or what because I assume you are
all right thanks bud that's very helpful
what
hi are you in there
is that actually you
all right that's fine
foreign
oh I can't see I'm stuck
I was in what was I in
oh
that's oh
ah all right well don't do that again
okay
then it wasn't uh Monty right here the
last time I saw him wasn't that a thing
I feel like maybe I'm supposed to be
avoiding him but I don't know exactly
where he is and who set up these pointy
wait a minute
Vani
all right well you went the wrong way
dummy
yeah try that again pal
yeah see how that we're gonna go for you
buddy hide in here no
all right well I think I go up there
if I can oh
why not
but why
okay
oh interesting and now it's fine
why why
oh
am I seeing some kind of Soul transfer
occurring
that's probably fine
oh
okey dokey then
weird oh hey I'm really finding the
secrets which this is not like me I
don't usually do okay I don't want that
from that Old headset game
oh the VR one
okay let's see where the the trail of
salt
I need your help Gregory Gregory I can
hear you
can hear me turn off all security turn
it all off security
what are you talking about
none of this makes sense
security knows find them and turn them
all off I can't get out until that
happens Gregory
nose
what the heck are those yeah well okay
that's realistic because I don't know
what the heck that is
weird
why is this all
what is this where is it
it really see oh hi I'm auntie
what's that about
it's not about anything
this is fascinating
what is that supposed to be
I think I mean just walking through this
just like what is that what is that what
is that and I know it's going to be
answered like relatively soon but I'm
still just very curious this is so
different than I was expecting
what is that
it's a buoy
this is buoy all right good Bowie oh
what is that
deactivate child nodes for oh like okay
in a hierarchy list I thought unless
you've moved
all right just new Mission objective
pops up
deactivate the children all right
yeah
will do why is this particular Barrel
really on this oh
no
take what
connect the matching Holograms be
careful not to cross the lines okay
like the the cupcakes so do I I no I
don't want a cupcake I do want a cupcake
oh
I get it the two different symbols are
the holidays okay
I'm what
wait a minute is this where I'm supposed
to go because I thought I was going the
way that I wasn't supposed to be going
then what was over on the other way
excuse my spin then what was
oh it's electrified of course I can't go
that way
I definitely knew that and knew this was
the right way to go I would never get
lost I definitely could have clambered
over this
all right
so
I'm glad that I'm leaving Monty behind
and that it's not going to be a threat
to me at any point
[Music]
all right
that's fine
photo op
okay
that's probably how vanny got a lot of
mine looking at what am I looking at
power of imagination
wow
it is indeed the power of imagination
you
oh
weird
uh what
huh
oh ah I'm picking up an anomalous entity
in the vanity Network please ask this
entity to leave the area immediately
like a ghost
if that doesn't work it is best to exit
AR mode and contact our 24-hour sport
line
hey you get out of here
all right that didn't work
um so what am I supposed to do
um
[Music]
wait a minute it's with you no no
all right
oh yeah that's not good
um
nothing to do about that though
I would never do anything about that
nope okay well that's not helpful I'm
gonna be in the real world for a bit and
then alternate reality kind of hurts my
eyes
what are you doing back there
what are you doing back there what are
you doing back there bud what are you
doing back there
interesting
okay
I hear something there's definitely not
anything over here
oh yeah what's with you
there's a bug on my shoulder oh good
well I definitely deactivated the
children
good good oh I see ah
why why
oh wait a minute hey leave you need to
go you're not welcome here get out of
here okay I'm asking you you don't do it
what
what what what
all right wait wait wait wait wait wait
that was a test I just want to test the
jump scare system can't know if it's a
FNAF game with other jump scare system
working properly so I had to
really see that was gonna be there yeah
I know I know shut up
so I didn't know I was supposed to
deactivate all of u's
also you got this weird veiny thing here
so
ah
all right that's good
so I just gotta look for more veins
well-founded
I'm gonna get it you're not gonna stop
me
oh oh you're right here oh oh oh crap oh
crap
Monty
Monty are you there
okay
seems all right hey it's a camera
I need some of those
all right but I think I did everything I
needed to do
some 2D activated so
all right we're going for it
take my Taser
that's easy for babies
it's for babies
not even tough not even tough
wait a minute wait a minute
you're not real wait you were not real
what happened to you
weird
bizarre okay oh hi God damn it you uh
what is this
oh
you know the vein did not need to be
that big
because I I this weird that I have to
say that but I need to say that the vein
didn't need to be that girthy
wait wait wait wait no
don't
that's what I thought
I don't know if that beats it does that
help if I just take off a mask
huh under the Raceway
all right get ready for a whole lot of
this watch this wonk
speed what is happening what is that
oh whoa oh that's that's not good
oh god oh wait
[Applause]
oh wait a minute
hey whoa oh you're stupid
oh you're dumb
oh you're done oh no oh no he's dumb
look in the camera the door is open the
door
the door is open
[Laughter]
okay okay
all right okay
ah fun tunnel
all right maybe I missed something
I'm sorry Marty I can't take you
seriously
laughs
ah man oh this is so scared Monty I'm so
scared don't do it whatever you're
planning don't
oh no he's gonna kill me
and then he's gonna kill me
all right where am I headed the door the
door is open thank you Gregory for
saying that because otherwise I
might have forgotten I probably wouldn't
have but I might have
because they really don't want people to
be lost again in this game
oh
okay all right
well
so I missed one of these robo's from
before I didn't know the objective was
to
shut down the babies
but uh maybe I can
don't do it
hey wait a minute oh wait a minute hey
wait a minute
hey wait a minute hold on oh wait a
minute that doesn't sound good
oh you you're there
what's with that oh I can't wait why why
why why why
what who's that with that chef with that
Chef who's there was something about
that chef
something didn't make any sense
someone who's weird about that chef
oh hi
okay I'm well that I didn't no wait hold
on wait stop wait don't I can't God
know me just kill me
it's so scary monster you're so scary I
can't oh the terror
[Applause]
oh no he's breaking no Monty don't do
this no Monty not like this
Monty no
there was something with that chef and I
wanted to know what it was and I this is
probably extremely dumb but you know me
I make extremely dumb decisions all the
time in these games so I might do
exactly that what's with you
oh nothing
okay well that was all just a big waste
of time I didn't need diet
[Applause]
that reminds me of like stuff well hi
pal how are you so just gonna let that
happen
then I'm fine probably
and I don't know what that is
well whatever not my problem
it's mostly the same
so who invented all this stuff that's
what I would like
that's why the chair was on the door
well too bad you'll never get through
there so yeah keep trying pal this guy
over here yeah keep going oh you'll get
it eventually oh okay
or whatever
maybe there's something interesting
about the door to see
I might be able to see through
nah
boring
okay here we go what okay here we go
okie dokie
all right
mashed potatoes
remember Jimmy
who's Jimmy
I don't remember
is that important
oh wait this is the security office
where
I got one of the special items oh oh no
oh no that's hilarious I love that
never stop smiling the customer is
always right okay
whatever you say oh for I forgot an
important detail so I actually have the
trailer ready the next trailer for iron
lung I'm not allowed to release it
because of the strike and I'm not saying
like oh that's terrible I'm trying to
get permission which I think I'll get
um but in case ever anyone was wondering
yes I am
I'm so eager what is this is this not a
ball why is there a vein on the ball
whatever
um so eager to share this with you guys
but it's uh oh okay it's um oh boy
oh that's not good oh that's not good
yeah I would love to take it off the
mask
I'm probably gonna die
holograms for babies
can I take this off now I'm going live
bye kind of Slenderman
thing you doing
anyway so as soon as I get approval for
that I will share it with you guys right
oh wait I should be quicker about this
no I shouldn't
[Music]
I I I don't mean to be crap
because it's so well
like it's great I just wanted just that
I love that can you actually get me oh
you were behind me
anyway
no all right goodbye
did you make it through
did he make it through oh he did no did
he no he didn't did he I don't know
Diddy
where am I going hi what are you doing
over there
100 of fatal accidents involve human
beings
not always I'm sure that
animals there could be fatal accidents
oh
my instincts are just so sharp
never stop smiling uh-huh
oh why are the pillars pulsating
this is super cool by the way I don't
know if I actually mentioned that this
is incredibly
cool
I do like it hello box
I just like the direction they've taken
it's not a direction that I thought they
would take
now if anybody knew what is going on
with you
I thought I was sniffing
why is it just the same hologram give me
something challenging
oh
all right I vaguely remember this area
it's weird I'm getting like little
Snippets of deja vu every once in a
while about
specific Zone but I can't tell I think
it's all the same spot it's a dead end
no you're a dead end do not despair this
is no dead end sometimes all you need is
a New Perspective check that camera
station
what camera station
this camera station doesn't seem to be
active however I'm detecting an unusual
signal put on the mask and check again
okay ah
fascinating
cameras now the way for thanks I I I got
that
just kind of curious what's going on
there
I don't know why
but all right
uh-huh so
hold on
I just go oh anomaly quarantine
what is this oh God I really thought it
was about to be like observation dude oh
it is gone
wow
oh God what what oh I had it on
see that is strange
was this always like that or was this
only after I put on the mask for the
first time I walked through a big and
now I'm in Superstar daycare
no way this is real that stream was
there before I looked at the camera
I swear
yeah there's nothing to worry about
everything appears to be perfectly
normal you must be seeing things
boy
boy you're right
that's on me for being an idiot so sorry
I apologize
hi what are you doing here
oh
I'm gonna be in the new world for a
little bit
okay where are you I'm in daycare is
there a way out of here get to the
daycare theater there's a way down to
the catwalks should help you get to the
Raceway uh-huh the Raceway okay
so
[Music]
right
if I remember the daycare which I
definitely don't
there are probably some bad things
occurring in the daycare
like a betrayal that occurred
from someone I thought was a friend
uh yeah that's fine
that's fine
okay
all fine
I'll definitely fine oh good
slide into fun oh this is us pop in for
a spell
for just just a little bit of fun you
know just just a little sneeze of fun
tiny dripping
all right that's gonna do it for this
episode thank you so much uh for
watching hope you're enjoying it so far
don't worry it's going to be plenty more
uh security breach DLC coming at you
soon
yeah and as always I'll see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]